رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان في اول
ظهور جماهيري له منذر محاوله الفاشله
لاغتياله الشهر الجاري
عمران خان اكد عزمه على المضيف فيما وصفه
بالكفاح لتحقيق الحريه الحقيقيه وجدد
اتهام الحكومه بالفساد وعدم الاهليه
وخيرها بين اجراء انتخابات مبكره ام
مواجهه العواقب ونوح باستقاله
جزءا من النظام السياسي الحالي سيخرج
نوابنا من كافه المجالس النيابيه
الاقليميه لهذا النظام الفاسد و ساستمع مع
رؤسائي حكوماتنا الاقليميه ونوابنا لتحديد
موعد مغادره المجالس كما اننا لن نتوجه
لاسلام اباد لتجنب اي اضرار
الحكومه اعتبرتها الان عمران خان قرارا
بالهزيمه واتهمته بالفشل في حياه الدعم
الشعبي لحركه وجدده اتهامها له بالعمل على
زعزعه استقرار البلاد وتحقيق مصالح شخصيه
الاستعدادها للحوار
انت
السياسيين
تتغير عندما يتحاورسا يرحم الشعب واترك
العناد والا ستكون مسؤول عن ارتفاع
الاسعار
الالاف من انصار عمران خان توجهه الى
مدينه المحاديه للعاصمه من كافه ارجاء
باكستان رافعين اعلام
بالرغم من تقارير امنيه حذرت من امكانيه
تعرض التظاهره للهجوم ارهابي الشعب جاء
هناك لدعوه عمران والفاسدين
نقول للحكومه المستورده ان المؤامره
الامريكيه لن تنجح ونحن ما اي قرار يتخذه
عمران خان وفي الوقت الذي تجاوزت فيه
الحكومه عاقبه تعيين قائد جديد للجيش
الاسرى خلال ثلاثات مع المعارضه وتاكيد
الجيش عزوفه عن التدخل في السياسه
يحذر مراقبون من استمرار الجمهود وتمسك
طرفي الازمه السياسيه
للخروج من الازمه وايجاد حل توافقين
وتجنيب البلاد المزيد من الازمات في ظل
التحديات الاقتصاديه والامنيه عبد الرحمن
الجيني العربيه